Merlin's beard we had six what already
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks the revisit of the Harry
Potter film franchise marches on and we
have arrived at the half-blood Prince
I'm not gonna beat around the bush I
like this one a lot I feel like this one
doesn't get talked about particularly
much and I can't tell if it's one people
have a lot of major issues with or not I
mean I could tell if I was parse a
little more research and I'm sure I'll
find out in the comment section but like
with say Goblet fire which I also quite
like I know what some of the issues
people have with that one are this one
again unless you're a book purist which
book beerus never liked the adaptations
i'm sorry they don't but unless that's
what's going on for you i think there is
a lot to like about this as a film in
and of itself and honestly as an
adaptation
it was interesting going back and
revisiting because I've always known I
liked this one but I honestly didn't
really know why I like this one
as much as I do and it hit me this time
it's because this is the first one since
at least Prisoner of Azkaban I would
argue since chamber of secrets that
feels like it's just happening at the
school it gives us classrooms again it
gives us that sense again it brings back
that vibe that has kind of been lost it
was it kind of it was largely started to
fade with Prisoner of Azkaban and this
is not criticism of Prisoner of Azkaban
or Goblet of Fire or
order the Phoenix but those all had much
bigger picture things that they needed
to focus on because prisoner of azkaban
had all of Harry's revelations about
Sirius and his family and all of that
going on
you still had some classroom stuff with
Lupin but it was starting to be on the
decline by then cuz we had him and we
had a little bit with Trelawney but you
could feel the non classroom stuff
starting to pull attention not just in
the climax but in the overall story and
the fourth one it was all about the
tournament
fifth one you had all this stuff going
on with Harry it was about his inner
turmoil and it was about umbrage taking
over the school and we lost the thread
on those classroom scenes on the feel of
the day to day school vibe and also I
feel like this has a bit more color in
it as well and I mean that quite
literally it's still fairly toned down
color it is fairly darkly lit but it
doesn't feel like everything's just blue
like it felt like there was a blue
filter over a lot of order of the
Phoenix that's not the case here colors
are toned down but they're there they're
not washed out it's not monotone it's
just dulled which works and makes sense
for where the story's going overall and
I think a big part of why we get as much
classroom stuff back is because we need
that for Slughorn to work and Slughorn
continues this series trend of having
its secret weapon being the casting
which is basically always perfect and
Jim Broadbent as Slughorn is just
perfect because like Slughorn is he's a
creep he's a creep of a character but
Jim Broadbent is such an affable
performer he brings such a likeability
inherently he just has that as an actor
and it doesn't make him suddenly not a
bit of a so you know a social climbing
creep but it makes you not automatically
hate him and his moments where he needs
to be more endear
and to come across as human Jim prepend
is able to sell that he does it really
really well I also feel like and this is
gonna be weird coming from me as much as
I don't care for romantic subplots
things like what went on with Ron and
lavender and yes quick sidenote
the whole thing that went on with the
lavender recasting cuz there was another
actress basically cast as lavender up
until this point but lavender was a
background character who never had any
lines and that actress was a person of
color and then as soon as lamda actually
has stuff to do they brought in a white
actress and that is kind of messed up
for girls what would you feel about
anything else they had cast it and then
they changed it it's a little bit weird
I guess they figure they could get away
with it because again she hadn't spoken
up to that point but like it's odd and a
little bit yeah but setting that aside
but I did want to acknowledge it like
the that sort of weird awkward first
relationship of this is exciting but
like now I kind of want to get out of it
that ron has gone with lavender I like
that that feels very teenager it feels
very school and honestly so does Ron's
thing with Hermione which I don't love
overall but I do by well enough I think
largely because by the by about the
third movie the writers and the
directors knew that these two were going
to end up becoming a thing so this felt
like it was getting planted and seeded
especially in like Goblet of Fire and a
little bit in order of the Phoenix so
this felt like a natural progression for
them Ginny and Harry not quite so much
that felt a little bit more out of the
blue and I think largely because of
Ginny kind of getting the short shrift
in earlier installments she was always
kind of there but that was it she was
just kind of there and it's not bad
their chemistry's oh hey but it's not
great I actually don't think daniel
radcliffe does romantic chemistry
especially well I
think it's limited to to her he didn't
really have it with Cho Chang either so
I just don't think he's that's I think
that's not really part of his acting
repertoire and I've seen him in a fair
amount of stuff and more often than not
if I've really liked him it's been in a
part that didn't really have a romantic
component going on so you know that just
kind of is there a draco malfoy some
really good stuff going on with this
performance and Tom ahead tom felton
really nails how scared he is like we
don't get enough time alone with him to
confirm this but like my read on this is
very much he is still trying to convince
himself that he wants this cuz he wanted
it for so long
now that he has it he is terrified and
deep down he probably knows he doesn't
want this but he's worked so hard for it
and he's so scared of what's going to
happen to him when he's pointing his
wand
Dumbledore breaking down when he says
he's gonna kill me the look on his face
oh my god la all the performances are so
top-notch in this there is an angst
about Snape that really pays off at the
end Gambon's Dumbledore I think this is
the best he ever was and also overall
this feels like a movie that makes the
world feel bigger it was starting to
feel incredibly confined to Hogwarts and
it's not like we never went to other
locations because we did there were you
know we had Diagon Alley we'd been to
the bar oh there were things like that
but it was usually only like one other
than the Dursleys one additional non
Hogwarts location per film and it still
largely felt kind of isolated but here
we get a little bit of everything
we get a nice mix we get the borough we
get the Three Broomsticks and we get the
house that they that Dumbledore finds
Slughorn in which honestly like we're
just in a house we're just in somebody's
house that doesn't happen and this and
it helps it feel like a bigger more
lived-in world we get that we get Diagon
Alley we get borgin and Burkes we get
all these little additional things the
the cave that Dumbledore and Harry go to
it makes it all feel bigger in a way
that the other films never really quite
captured I don't think I think that's
another thing that I really like about
this film that really kind of upped
things then in a specific realm that
hadn't really been pulled off before if
I'm gonna have other than some of the
nitpicky things I already mentioned from
an adaptation standpoint I'd say there's
one primary failing that this has and
that is it fails to deliver on Harry's
hero-worship of the half-blood Prince
who was the former owner of his potions
textbook and who had a bunch of notes in
there and Harry's starting to idolize
whoever this person he doesn't even know
who it was the movie doesn't really
capture that in the movie the the
textbook is really just it's basically a
cheat sheet for him it doesn't do a good
job of hammering home how dependent and
how much of a security blanket the thing
became for Harry not just for academics
but like in general he really related to
whoever this person was and because they
don't sell that sort of borderline hero
worship of Harry towards the half-blood
Prince the revelation at the end that it
was Snape doesn't land the way that it
should because they didn't sell that
aspect well enough it was so much better
in the book so that is one specific
aspect of the adaptation that
do you think actually does kind of fail
and I will absolutely admit to that they
needed to do a better job on that part
and they didn't but there's just so so
much that I love about this so many of
the bigger thing of big thing approaches
the overall feel and flow of it it it
feels in many ways like it's like it's
pulling back in like it's almost comma
because you know we had the very intense
stuff going on with the Triwizard
Tournament and then with Umbridge there
things feel a little bit more relaxed
yes there's darkness there's bad stuff
going on in the world but like at
Hogwarts all right we're just going to
class okay
to then get the rug pulled out from
under us with what Haring double do
growth go through in that cave and then
Dumbledore spoiler dying it's a really
effective contrast within the film
itself not just a contrast of the series
overall like contrasting from where we
started like within this specific
narrative it is contrasting quite well
it's got a lot of wonderful little
moments I really love the performance
from Radcliffe when he has had the
liquid luck he's this this great he's
basically got drunk swagger is what he's
got and it's wonderful and hilarious and
again the actors are so good in their
parts they don't need a big highlighted
moment to still like have something that
I will always remember like McGonagall
just had I will always remember this one
little moment where she tells Potter oh
no you can take
potions advanced potions because
Slughorn doesn't require you to have had
his high grades and that as Snape did
and then she looks and sees wheezing ago
and says Potter take Weasley with you he
looks far too happy over there it's just
this one little moment like oh maggie
smells so good because they're all good
and they know these characters and they
know what they're doing and they know
how to get something out of even a small
amount of screen time there are some
issues with this for me the the big one
is
around the the actual half-blood prince
element of the story not handled great
not handled poorly just kind of actually
failed to be handled very much at all
which is a shame especially given that
that's the title but most of everything
else going on here I really like I like
the build I like the feel I like the
flow I like the look
I love the performances I think it this
is the strongest performances from
almost everybody in the entire film up
to this point I really like this one I
don't know if I'm in a minority on that
suppose I'll find out Harry Potter and
the half-blood Prince what you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let us
talk about it bunch of stuff you can do
as well you can like and subscribe both
of which helped me out and also there's
the Bell you know if you want to keep up
with whenever i get new stuff up which
is four videos a week these days also
patreon you can help support me keep
this whole thing going and there's other
things besides link to my various social
medias like Twitter and patreon and
merch and all sorts of stuff click on
things or don't you don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]